[Música]
Bienvenidos a la entrevista de Franz 24
hoy nos acompaña josep borrell alto
representante de la Unión Europea para
los asuntos exteriores y la política de
seguridad Muchísimas gracias por estar
con nosotros Hola buenos días Gracias
usted está aquí en el marco de la cumbre
iberoamericana en la que muchos países
han expresado su esperanza en que la
presidencia protemporánea española del
Consejo de la Unión Europea facilite el
reencuentro entre bloques durante esta
presidencia española se puede llegar a
ratificar asuntos pendientes como sería
el acuerdo entre la Unión Europea y el
mercosur Bueno
antes hay que acabar de ratificar chile
y probablemente México
en mercosur tenemos ya un acuerdo de
principio alcanzado en el 2019
pero necesita mucho más trabajo y si
alguien lo puede hacer es dudar a
presidencia española que tendrá un
interés mucho mayor por razones lógicas
y cuáles son los principales obstáculos
ahora mismo para esta ratificación De
qué manera podemos completar el acuerdo
con elementos que garanticen la
protección ambiental Y eso en ese
momento entra en una cierta
contradicción con aspectos de tipo
productivo en algunos algunos países y
también la competencia con los
productores europeos no puedo decirle
que el tema esté resuelto pero sí que
ayer quedó muy claro la voluntad tanto
por parte de Argentina con quien se
entrevistó el presidente del gobierno
español como de la Unión Europea de
intentar aportar de una vez por todas un
acuerdo que lleva más de 20 años
negociándose porque el presidente de
Argentina por ejemplo llegó a expresar
que la cuestión medioambiental era una
excusa para ocultar el proteccionismo de
ciertos estados europeos
no exactamente se puede pensar que hay
determinadas medidas que tienen
consecuencias sobre sectores productivos
se pueden interpretar como una medida de
protección a los productores europeos
pero la preocupación por las
consecuencias ambientales de un aumento
de los flujos comerciales es algo que
está muy vivo la sociedad europea es un
sentimiento legítimo la parte importante
de la población que dice sí comercio Sí
pero en igualdad de condiciones sí
comercio Sí pero teniendo en cuenta el
impacto que esto tiene sobre el medio
ambiente y la Unión Europea está tomando
medidas que son objeto de críticas Por
una parte no les parecen suficientes a
uno si les parecen excesivas a otras se
ve difícil que este acuerdo se ratifique
en 2023 no lo veo imposible pero no le
oculto que tiene dificultades para eso
está la acción política y el compromiso
de todos en trabajar para conseguirlo
pero son preocupaciones
por ambas partes que hay que tomar en
consideración hablando de preocupaciones
la minuta que no se haya conseguido
condenar por consenso la invasión a rusa
de Ucrania en esta Cumbre no se citas
precisamente a Ucrania por la oposición
de algunos países que puede usted
imaginar Quiénes son pocos pero como las
decisiones se toman por el acuerdo
unánime no se pudo tomar pero se dice
sin citar a Ucrania que hay que respetar
la integridad territorial de los estados
y hay que respetar la soberanía de los
estados Bueno a buen entendedor pocas
palabras devastan está claro que cuando
se dice esto ahora es en una referencia
lo que está ocurriendo en Ucrania
Lamento sí Lamento que no se haya podido
citar por la oposición de algunos países
por sus especiales relaciones con Rusia
pero creo que la comunidad
latinoamericana y la inmensa mayoría de
los latinoamericanos condena sin duda lo
que es una flagrante violación del
derecho internacional invasión por ahí
simple en el más puro estilo
imperialista de un país y precisamente
no Esta es una guerra que ha preocupado
bueno ha centrado la atención de la
Unión Europea desde hace ya un año la
Unión Europea ha implementado 10
paquetes de sanciones ha enviado ayuda
militar masiva a kiev y sin embargo la
guerra continúa Como qué van a hacer
para que termine esta guerra si no lo
hubiéramos hecho Putin ya estaría y gif
les ayuda militar que no ha sido tan
masiva como usted dice porque al
contrario hemos graduado de manera que
no nos convirtiesen beligerantes cosa
que no queremos ser porque si no
estaríamos provocando la tercera guerra
mundial y obviamente no lo queremos
Gracias de esa ayuda que tiene que
continuaría sido capaz de resistir ha
sido capaz de resistir de rechazar al
Invasor si suspendemos la ayuda militar
tenemos mañana a las tropas rusas en la
frontera de Polonia Más allá de resistir
Cómo se puede terminar
qué creen que Ucrania debería estar
dispuesto a aceptar para llegar a una
negociación de paz pero me pregunto a
usted qué es lo que Rusia debería estar
dispuesto a aceptar porque Ucrania ha
sido invadida de que hay un gran agresor
y un agredido Sí por supuesto porque
pone usted el peso de la carga en la
parte del agredido y no la parte del
agresor porque para lograr un acuerdo de
paz ambas partes van a tener que llegar
a un punto de consenso Sí pero usted me
ha preguntado por la parte agredida no
por la parte del agresor aquí quién
tiene que decir lo que hay que hacer
para poner fin a la guerra es el que la
ha empezado es decir Ucrania no tendría
que aceptar ninguna cesión territorial
yo no sé lo que Ucrania tiene que hacer
es un país soberano independiente y a
ellos les corresponde saberlo yo lo que
sí sé es que hay que respetar el derecho
internacional y que no se puede permitir
que un país poderoso porque tiene más
fuerza que el vecino lo invada el
arranque parte territorio es decir usted
como alto representante de la Unión
Europea para los asuntos exteriores no
tiene una opinión o no me puede decir lo
que considera la Unión Europea que puede
llevar a que se alcance una salida
pacífica a este conflicto que tendría
que aceptar Ucrania para terminar con la
guerra
decir lo mismo me gustaría más que me
preguntara por lo que tiene que aceptar
Rusia pero fíjese pero fíjese todo el
mundo quiere la paz y yo también a mí no
me gusta gastar el dinero comprando
municiones preferiría gastarlo en ayuda
al desarrollo todo el mundo dice querer
la paz incluso Putin dice querer la paz
mientras continúa bombardeando vamos a
dejar de ser hipócritas y vamos a hacer
frente a la realidad la realidad es que
es un país invadido bombardeado
destruido sistemáticamente por alguien
mucho más poderoso que él
la paz Sí pero queremos una paz justa
una paz que no sea la paz del vencido La
paz de los cementerios tenemos una paz
Que respete el derecho internacional y
el derecho a Ucrania vivir de forma
libre e independiente y para conseguir
esa Paz Ucrania tiene que ganar la
guerra y para que gane la guerra Hay que
seguir apoyando a la militarmente y
cuando Ucrania crea que debe y puede
conseguir una paz negociada estaremos
detrás de ella estamos apoyando el plan
de paz el presidente zelenske el
presidente presentado un par de paz que
yo sepa Putin no he hecho en más que
seguir bombardeando usted para que para
considerar que Ucrania ha ganado la
guerra qué punto se debería llegar
es una pregunta retórica
no hay una respuesta concreta lo que
está claro es que Rusia ya ha perdido la
guerra
ha perdido porque pretendía conquistar
que iba en 15 días en lanzó una
operación neurotransportada que les
fracasó fue rechazado en las afueras de
quicio he visto decenas de tanques rusos
reventados en las calles de gif y ahora
está retirándose Estoy seguro que Putin
Si hubiera sabido que un año después de
lanzar la guerra estaría como está se lo
Hubiera pensado dos veces por tanto Hay
que seguir apoyando militarmente a
Ucrania y la verdad no comprendo muy
bien la crítica por ejemplo cuando
estamos enviando municiones a Ucrania O
sea la gente está de acuerdo en que se
manden cañones pero no en que se manden
municiones Entonces para qué sirven los
cañones
y precisamente usted ha dicho que la
Unión Europea intenta no convertirse en
beligerante para evitar una escalada
usted ha tenido la escalada en algún
momento todos los momentos usted no Ha
oído ir amenazando con el uso del arma
nuclear es decir Usted vive preocupado
de que vaya a escalar este conflicto yo
creo que no hay que hablar del tema
nuclear porque al hacerlo le hacemos el
juego a Putin Putin creía que como
teníamos una dependencia energética tan
grande no seríamos capaces de ayudar a
Ucrania porque nos podía cortar el gas
precisamente hablando de esta
dependencia energética Le quiero
preguntar si puede recordar septiembre
del año pasado Qué pasó por su mente
cuando explotaron los gasoductos
norstream
alguien tenía interés en que sus
acueductos no pudieran funcionar
pero no sé quién es ni creo que se sepa
nunca Usted cree que a lo mejor no se
llega a saber nunca
francamente no lo sé y si quiere que le
diga la verdad en este momento lo que
nos preocupa a los europeos es primero
garantizar nuestra independencia
energética cosa que ya hemos conseguido
en tres meses hemos podido prescindir el
Ruso y ayudar a un país tengo que
insistirle en ello porque es el mensaje
que hay que lanzar en los ciudadanos del
mundo a un país que no era una amenaza
para Rusia donde no había ningún
despliegue militar de la otan donde no
había fuerzas extranjeras que amenazaron
a Rusia que ha sido invadido y está
siendo destruido
Ese es el mensaje que lanzar a los
ciudadanos Esa no es una guerra de los
europeos que no afecta a los demás todo
el mundo se ha visto afectado porque ha
provocado Un aumento del precio de la
energía y de los alimentos Por qué
Porque Rusia ha bloqueado la salida de
de Ucrania porque ha impedido que 20
millones de toneladas de trigo
almacenadas en los siglos de Ucrania
puedan llegar a la gente del mundo que
comía de ellos
perdónenme Déjenme seguir eso es lo que
hay que explicarles a la gente esta no
es una guerra de los europeos entre
europeos ni en Europa es una guerra
contra el orden internacional Sí ya sé
que en el pasado ha habido otras guerras
que todavía las hay muchas y nos
preocupamos de todas pero no podemos
aceptar el discurso de decir eso a mí no
me afecta Claro que afecta Claro que le
afecta usted paga la energía más cara
paga los alimentos más caros como
consecuencia de que Rusia ha invadido un
país y usted precisamente se ha referido
a esta guerra en otros momentos también
como una guerra de narrativas que lo
llaman ahora como se vence una narrativa
porque esta narrativa que usted me está
me está planteando no es no es la única
evidentemente Rusia tiene otra narrativa
es muy buena haciendo narrativas falsas
pasa el día diciendo que a la
consecuencia de que en África no haya
trigo es las sanciones que la Unión
Europea le ha impuesto Pero cómo se
puede tener esta desvergüenza cuando
usted tiene sus barcos de guerra
bloqueando 20 millones de toneladas que
están que no se pueden exportar nuestras
sanciones no afectan a las exportaciones
de alimentos ni de fertilizantes porque
precisamente las hemos excluido Me
pregunto cómo se puede vencer una
narrativa pues haciendo entrevistas como
la que usted me está haciendo Y
aprovechando esta ocasión para
explicarle a quien la vea Qué es lo que
está pasando y por qué usted se pensaba
hace un año antes de que empezara esta
guerra hace un poco más de un año que el
orden internacional se precipitaría de
la forma que ha ocurrido no con esta
nueva dimisión tan marcada entre Estados
Unidos y la Unión Europea y digamos a
China y Rusia alguien me dijo cuando
íbamos a tener primero epidemia y
después una guerra son hechos que
ciertamente no teníamos previstos la
prueba de que no los teníamos previstos
es que Europa lleva muchos años
desarmándose lleva muchos años
reduciendo su gasto militar lleva muchos
años disminuyendo el stock de sus
almacenes militares porque la guerra no
estaba ya en nuestro Horizonte mental
pensábamos que eramos desterrado para
siempre pero desde otoño del año 2021
empezaron a sonar tambores de guerra
empezaron a ver que Rusia concentraba
sus tropas que ponía 150.000 hombres
armados hasta los dientes en la frontera
de Ucrania en Navidades ya se veía venir
y cuando en Navidades visité el frente
el Primer Ministro de Ucrania me dijo
nos van a invadir y quiero hacerle una
pregunta cuando nos invadan ustedes nos
van a ayudar ya sé que no van a mandar
sus soldados a luchar con nosotros pero
nos van a dar por lo menos las armas que
necesitamos para defendernos eso es muy
interesante porque es elnsky
prácticamente hasta el día antes de la
invasión digamos llamaba a la calma
Entonces esta guerra se vio venir unos
meses antes de que empezara la invasión
total y no se pudo evitar soy todo lo
posible para evitarlo hubo multitud de
contactos diplomáticos yo mismo con el
con el Primer Ministro perdón con el
ministro asunto de exteriores rusos hizo
todo lo posible por evitarlo pero cuando
usted concentra 150.000 hombres armados
hasta los dientes en la frontera de un
país no lo hace para asustar y al final
ya vimos que no lo hizo para asustar y
para terminar muy rápidamente porque ya
nos quedamos sin tiempo en medio de este
nuevo orden mundial que papel para
América Latina América Latina está su
evaluada
América Latina es un continente en paz
no hay guerras entre los estados
latinoamericanos sí las sociedades
latinoamericanas son sociedades
desiguales y violentas pero es un
continente Pacífico Hace mucho tiempo
que hay una guerra que no hay Guerras en
América Latina y eso hoy en el mundo es
un gran activo merecena tiene una
población joven y cada vez mejor formada
tiene las mayores reservas de los
minerales que van a ser utilizados en la
transformación digital veré que latina
puede ser lo que fue el golfo Pérsico
cuando empezamos a hacer utilizar
motores de gasolina puede hacer para no
ser exfoliada y ser digamos hacerse
valer América Latina seguro que no va a
ser expoliada porque tiene la capacidad
política de defender sus intereses tiene
sus Minas tiene sus minerales puede
exportarlos en bruto o puede refinar
refinarlos y construir baterías aquí y
la Unión Europea va a contribuir a eso
la Unión Europea va a contribuir a que
América Latina aproveche esta
circunstancia para dar un salto delante
en su prosperidad económica y mejorar su
cohesión social y juntos europeos y
latinoamericanos O iberoamericanos creo
que podemos jugar un papel constructivo
en el mundo frente a esta de tu
monopolio
confrontación que vemos venir entre
China y Estados Unidos la Unión Europea
es una fuerza de paz América Latina son
continente Pacífico entre los dos
podemos construir aquel mundo también lo
sea Y lamentablemente se nos acaba el
tiempo pero muchísimas gracias por haber
estado con nosotros gracias gracias y a
ustedes Muchísimas gracias sigan con
esta y más información